pues en una conferencia de prensa
anunciada con un muy poquito tiempo de
antelación y de urgencia el ministro de
la presidencia feliz bolaños anunció o
dijo que exactamente que los dos
teléfonos móviles que mencionaba raúl
los institucionales fueron espiados en
mayo y junio de 2021 y que del teléfono
del presidente del gobierno pedro
sánchez se habían extraído casi tres
gigabytes de información mientras que es
del de la presidenta del de la ministra
de defensa se habían extraído tan sólo
nueve megas lo que no dijeron o lo que
no quisieron hacer es apuntar a ningún
país o gobierno o entidad que pueda
estar detrás del espionaje pero lo que
sí dijeron fue que fue un ataque ilícito
y externo y por externo se refieren a
que son ajenos a cualquier organismo
institucional y que no cuentan con
ninguna autorización judicial por ahora
lo que ha hecho el ejecutivo es entregar
los informes del centro de criptología a
la audiencia nacional para que
investigue el caso y desde el gobierno
seguirán investigando o verificando
todos los teléfonos institucionales de
los miembros del gao para verificar si
tienen o no instalado este software
israelí clara marina y es que este
anuncio se da apenas dos semanas después
de que se revelara que al menos 60
líderes independentistas catalanes y
también vascos habrían sido sujetos a
este tipo de espionaje que reacciones ha
habido hasta el momento sobre este caso
también marina
claro y es que aunque como yo decía el
gobierno no ha querido apuntar a nadie a
ningún motivo detrás de este espionaje
el momento en el que se dio es decir
mayo y junio del año pasado tiene mucho
que ver con el proceso independentista
porque eran justos semanas o días antes
de que el presidente del gobierno
indultará a los nueve condenados y
encarcelados por el proceso
independentista de declaración de
nulidad unilateral de independencia que
se dio en 2017 y además otro dato
importante de política internacional era
el momento de crisis migratoria y
diplomática con marruecos por la acogida
del líder del frente polisario en españa
así que desde algunos sectores del
independentismo catalán como por ejemplo
del ex presidente del gobierno de
cataluña aseguran que recriminan más
bien al gobierno que justo ahora ahora
sí ahora que se ven afectados le pongan
atención a este tema cuando ellos llevan
semanas denunciando lo y piden que se
depuren responsabilidades en el gobierno
por lo pronto ahora el miércoles que
viene de esta semana va a hablar en el
congreso de los diputados la titular de
defensa
que es la líder del consejo nacional de
inteligencia el cn y que apunta o es
apuntado por ciertos sectores como
posible ente detrás de este espionaje a
los líderes independentistas catalán